Hey guys how is it going?
Um, I know this is a late upload
and I'm kind of late to my own 12 million party,
but that's because I didn't know that I was going to be making
a dedicated video like this.
Because after me and the boys worked very hard on 'WOOF'
and, we set out to make that bigger and better
and funnier than 'MEOW',
and we think it's good, but I'll leave the judgement up to you guys.
You guys can check out 'WOOF', compare the two,
I don't care, links are in the description.
Um, but as far as this video goes,
I didn't want to do a dedicated video because
part of me feels like I must sound annoying?
For how many times I repeat myself.
And...
I-I just got out of the shower, it's why my hair's still wet
and I was thinking about...
You know, this whole Youtube thing that I do
and this whole channel that I have
and this dialogue that I have with you guys
and um...
It-it's really interesting, because...
On April 4th of 2012, I believe that's the day
I might be wrong, it's so long ago now,
I uploaded my first video to YouTube
and when I think about that...
You know, I think back on...
You know, the smaller aspect of the channel that I have-
had-
and I think about the more intimate moments that I had
uh...
during that time.
And a lot of it is because it was very fresh and new
and it was like a new adventure to me
and it was new and interesting and everything was new and,
and every single milestone that I got, you know,
was a new adventure and a new amazing thing
and no one had ever done that, even though a lot of people had done that already.
But for me, it was really new and interesting and amazing
and... you know, that feeling has not really diminished all that much.
It still amazes me, you know, 12 million.
It's like 'What the hell is that? Is that a number?'
I don't even know!
And so, you know I think about these things-
I'm sorry if I got lettuce in my teeth, I dunno-
- but I think about these things and I look back and I'm like
'Did I feel the same way? Oh yeah, I did!'
I remember, I was just a dumb goof that was amazed
that anyone watched his videos in the first place.
And...
You know, I...
I was, ah, I looked back right before I recorded this video
I got a little teary-eyed because there's one video that I can always look back on
and remember and...
It always gets me and some of you guys have seen it
if you haven't, I'll link it in the description too.
It's the... Markiplier Project 20000 subscriber milestone video, and...
That video...
is very, very special to me.
And mostly-mostly because of the part where Bob speaks
I can't even-
Just thinking about it kinda gets me
I, I remember the part where Bob speaks
and I have it like, right here
and I'm afraid to play it 'cause I'm gonna start crying
and it's not gonna be good, but-
What...
You know...
Ah, fuck it.
Bob: 'He is exactly the guy that you think he is.'
'Um, I know there are a lot of people on the internet'
'Who uh, you know, seem kind of fake'
'and uh, and people have accused Mark before of, you know, his reactions aren't sincere'
'he yells just to be ridiculous. But..'
'He's exactly the guy that it seems like he is.'
'I've been friends with him for years now, and...'
*Bob chuckles*
'It's just so great to see people finally appreciate what I've always known was-'
Mark: *interrupting* Okay, anyway.
It's, it's the moment where Bob, you know he vouches for me, and...
The fact that he does that is...
It's- it's, it's really meaningful to me.
And, you know, that- that...
And everything else that everyone said in the video,
and the things that people have said in videos down the road-
Goddammit!
Gaaah I didn't want to do this!
Ergh!
The things that people have said in other videos that are dedicated to me
and the fact that anything's dedicated to me at all,
is... you know, astonishing!
It's incredible, it's so stupid that I deserve any of this!
I don't! I don't deserve any of this! And...
You know...
I'm really, really, really grateful.
I really, really am grateful!
I'm so grateful, you guys don't know...
You guys don't know like, what I've been through!
To get here!
Ahhh.
[Grunting]
Ah man, you guys don't know how grateful I am
and you guys don't know how grateful I am that I get to do this
and I say it over and over and that's where I'm afraid that it's coming off as being ridiculous,
'cause I, I repeat myself so much!
I say the same thing every time I do a milestone video, I say the same damn thing!
But I am!
I'm really grateful!
Like, I really, sincerely am.
I love doing this,
and I love the fact I get to make videos for you guys!
And, I know there's a lot of like pessimism on YouTube
and there's a lot-
There's always been stupid shit going on on YouTube
and trolls here and there, that's always existed.
But, I've always been so proud of what you guys have done
and the stances that you guys have taken
and not letting small things like that bother you,
because there's so many bigger problems
than the stupid things that people argue about.
Oh man,
and it's just- it's good to know that...
We, here, can do something really cool.
And this weekend, if you didn't know, 26th we're doing a charity livestream
I don't know what charity for, I haven't even had the brainpower to think about it, but...
Just...
Like, thank you guys so much for being here
and thank you to my friends...
You know, who's stuck with me and, you know...
I think, like, there's people that I've disappointed on the way coming up here
and there's people that have been-
Aww, Lego...
I think the boys are home.
But, you know, there're people that I've-
I've...
Ah, forget it. You know there've been people I've disappointed
and I've tried my best to make everyone happy.
And I know I'm not gonna make everyone happy.
I know for a fact I'm not gonna make everyone happy.
But, just thank you guys so much for being here
and thank you for believing in what I do.
And thank you for...
Being a part of this and what I do,
because that's really special.
And the boys are definitely home, so I need to wipe my tears
before they start making fun of me.
So, anyway.
Thank you guys again so much for watching
and thank you for 12 million subscribers.
I'm sorry, I shed tears again,
didn't mean to do it.
I'm a frickin' mess.
But this is all you get, this is all you get.
This is the Markiplier you get, he's...
it's as dumb and stupid as it is.
So thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always,
I will see YOU
in the next video!
Bye-bye!